bailey oberg making his 20th start of
the season trying to bounce back from a
rough start against the toronto blue
jays gonna have to use that fastball and
have a little bit better location to be
successful and that'll bring up now
marcus simeons and the blue jays have
seven righties in the lineup tonight
fastball hit well left center field it's
going to split the outfielders and get
to the fence
so he tried with a couple of sliders
couldn't put him away went back to the
fastball and simeon's got a double one
two
swung on and misty struck him out it was
down and off the plate squirts away from
jeffers he tags pachette on the back and
bailey ober does give up that full count
double the simian but he leaves him
stranded at second base we played a half
inning at target field we're scoreless
twins coming up against jose barrios on
your home baseball as the twins will get
another look
at someone with whom they are very
familiar their former teammate jose
barrios jose barrios has been a terrific
pitcher for a long time spent six
seasons with the minnesota twins before
the trade at the trade deadline this
year and we'll face luisa rise former
teammate first pitch delivered and it's
quickly lined into left center field for
a big shed welcome home jose barrios
clothesline single the other way for
luisa rise and there's a man aboard to
kick things off here in the home first
up and in and buxton will take a walk
and it's a rough first inning for
barrios 2-2 pitch swing gonna miss got
him with a change-up donaldson down on
strikes one two fastball swinging a mess
ceno goes in the glove back-to-back
strikeouts for barrios and he minimizes
the early traffic by stranding runners
at first and second oscar hernandez
facing bayley over got him
fast ball up and away
and over with his second straight
strikeout i'll be interested to see what
they hear
swinging missed by corey dickerson tacky
or not
he wasn't hitting that ball it's the
third strikeout for bailey over two
scoreless from the big right-hander
going back for the twins in the bottom
of two next in a scoreless game from
target field nick gordon big night for
him last night three hits including a
three-run home run and an rbi double
he's allowed nine earned runs in those
last five starts and he just made quick
work of gordon for his third consecutive
strikeout
exhales rocks into the line the 2-2
curve ball swinging a miss jose barrios
will end a 1-2-3 second inning with
strikeouts two innings gone by still
nothing across between the twins and the
blue jays tonight well santiago espinal
all smiles today back with the team
starting at third it is great to see
espinal back with a big club and he's in
the swing of things right away
lines the first pitch he sees down the
left field line for a lead-off double
third bottom of the order angleton
simmons then we'll flip the card for a
rise in buckstone special it is to be a
part of an organization and leave a
footprint and imprint fingerprints all
over an organization as simmons so we
survived with simmons at first and
nobody out here in the third inning
another hit for a rise this one going
into the corner simmons round second on
his way to third a slow roll to the wall
simmons coming around third he's heading
home a rise with an rbi triple he has
the approach you can see he worked the
count got him a fastball they just
leaked back over the heart of the plate
they had him shaded towards center field
so hernandez had a long way to go and
happily i stand corrected i talked in
the first inning how you don't get many
opportunities against someone like
barrios and now here in the third a walk
a triple still nobody out and now buxton
to the plate
infield drawn in
byron first pitch hacking cracks one
deep to center deep into the minnesota
night and gone
number 15 for byron buxton
a first pitch two-run blast off jose
barrios and it's three-nothing twins
boxing went up there ready to hit and
got him a breaking ball just road up
there over the heart of the plate
not just like they didn't hit it hard
but
you can see springer turn it's like no
that ball is out of here two run bomb
a walk triple home run
and now polanco the pitch
curveball outside corner strike three
called
and a fastball there for
strike three six strikeouts for barrios
vladimir guerrero
and ober gets some swinging over the top
of a breaking ball guerrero strikes out
for the first out on one ball of two
strikes to beau buchet still in there
swung out and missed on a high fastball
as bayley ober picks up strikeout number
five here in the
top half of the fourth inning gordon
struck out swinging his first time up
it'll be gordon rooker and jeffers in
the twins fourth inning have a better
outcome than last time
and he pokes a base into left and
another productive at-bat after the
second strike for nick gordon you look
at what he's done
you know he's he's had some
two-strike hits got a base stealer at
first nobody out and rooker at the plate
rooker with a liner left another base
hat so in every inning but the second
twins have had their first two base or
two first two batters reach base
and there's strike three called
strikeout number seven on the night for
barrios so now corey dickerson who
struck out in his first at-bat tonight
2-2 broken battle roller through the
left side a base hit dickerson goes the
opposite way he'll lose the lumber but
the blue jays get a base runner with one
down here in the fifth inning
two and two
high fastball
and over completes the fifth inning he's
picked up six strikeouts in five shutout
innings he has struck out josh donaldson
twice tonight
and he got him strikes him out for the
third time in the game
and to five into minneapolis twins three
blue jays nothing 82 extra base hits 39
doubles couple of triples 41 home runs
and simeon is all over it left center
field and it is gone
number 42 for marcus simeon and the blue
jays are on the board
well what a pretty swing
that was a high curve ball and he had a
pretty good idea we're not going to get
any fastballs from ober after he hit
that fastball for a double his first
time up but he got a hanger and really
jumped all over
hit it to the back of the twins bullpen
and deep left center and
finally the blue jays can break out that
home run jacket i mean this is how you
hang and breakable you just commit you
stay on top of it and drive it out
to deep left center
is going to watch it bang off the back
of that back wall high above that twins
bullpen
that's a start bottom six
jose barrios is back out on the bound to
face his former mates
swing and a miss to get ceneaux
nine strikeouts now for barrios we're
going to throw him a change up here
and he got him with a change up and
that's strikeout number 10 for jose
maria's
blue jays down by two as they get ready
to come up in the seventh
with the lead the twins are trying to
manage that
driven to right
cave challenge right away going back
leaping making the catch on a warning
drag
jk with a great break
getting a high five from byron buxton
just check into the game now you gotta
race back to the track to make a catch
you can see jake focus
time has jumped perfectly there have
been some well hit outs
to the twins outfield
boxton's got two line drives that ball
hit very well
columbia to go through the meat of this
blue jay lineup
driven to right
cave coming in game over
coleman on five pitches
closes out a 3-1 twins win
you